mana karim benzema el delantero francés
del real madrid marcó tres goles al
chelsea en la ida de los cuartos de
final de champions league lleva 24 goles
en liga tiene 34 años karim benzéma está
viviendo una especie de segunda juventud
que ha hecho que ha pasado para que
explote de esta manera ahora en el real
madrid son dos cosas lo primero es que
él aprovechó todo este tiempo para
mejorar sus condiciones técnicas esos
registros que no los dominaba antes pero
luego se convirtió en eso que se llamó
bien de un futbolista total es un
futbolista que está por encima de
cualquier sistema o de cualquier esquema
de un entrenador porque porque ya no
solo a mí que me pasa cuando analizo
benzema gente que entiende una
contradicción primero no veo como el 9
clásico que tiene todos los registros
para definir cabeceo pierna derecha con
izquierda todos esos recursos del 9
clásico pero luego es el sueño del
fútbol moderno del fútbol actual y es un
jugador que entiende su rol a partir del
espacio de los movimientos que puedo
hacer de como asociarse con el
mediocampo y eso le está explotando muy
bien ancelotti ahora también es un
jugador que a través de los años ha
logrado personalidad y eso lo tienen muy
pocos que saber ser influyente en
partidos tan complicados como estos así
que está volviéndose en un futbolista
demasiado completo y eso es lo que hace
que hoy en día después de la salida de
cristiano rolando no sólo haya llenado
ese hueco en cuanto a la cantidad de
goles que pueda anotar sino a cómo entra
en el sistema muy bien de carlo
ancelotti para mí sin duda alguna el
mejor delantero del momento ahora mismo
en europa